alter ist ein krasser kampf alter ich
habe noch nie so einen klassenkampf
erlebt kommentierte der steverstadt
doch der schneemann ist doch noch da
alter ist das krass ich habe noch nie so
eine krasse kampf erlebte super smash
mob junge das musst du dir auf jeden
fall nach ihren job
hallo alle super special ops genau zu
super smash mouth zusammen mit kran
kraft sei der gerade total war laut nein
was laut aber nicht versteuert dass die
gern im coolen ein mikrofon was sie in
cooler typ empfohlen hat mein großer
bruder andy wollen der die wsk genau da
schlecht konstatiert der luke empfohlen
und du weißt es bei mir sieht wir nehmen
das bald beim ihr seht dann habe ich das
nicht von max sondern von mir erst mal
klar steinschaden und glaube ich spielen
super special ops ich schaue mal eben
jener arena 1 genauer findet die ip in
der beschreibung falls es selber spielen
wolf als cool findet mein flex ist ein
richtig cooler star war
find ich finde das super aufgebaut mit
der ganzen scoreboards rechts am rand
und was alles entstand dass der service
vor allem das zeitigt hefti ich habe
irgendwie alles gehört er ist komplett
simpel auf du wirst mit importierter
server wie komme ich denn ihr weg
witwatersrand ich packe wir sind sofort
wieder okay wir sind jetzt in einem game
trennen und ich weiß nicht was ich von
der klasse nehmen soll empfiehlt mir mal
gute klassen
ich heiße ich habe damals immer mit
ihnen möchten damals immer gekämpft
damals wartet schon fast immer mit dem
skelett gekämpft aber ich weiß schon
gibt ob es das noch gibt doch da ist es
örtlich spyder genommen nein des teams
des wetters geldwertes beider institute
klasse des täters gehabt habe ich mir
ganz sicher keine saskia ja stimmt ja
genau genau genau genau genau
ah ja das ok kommerz - und wir haben
sogar ein thema das ist eigentlich genau
der falsche spielmodus und über thema zu
quatschen was geht eigentlich ein
schnell maxi nicht fahren zusammen in
den urlaub wir beiden schultypen oder
anderen leuten auch noch und sagt man
mir nach sylt ist leben in rottweil
kellner das thema ran aber schon party
schreibt er auch da seid vielleicht
sieht man sich ja den christen hier
vielleicht ein paar von einen abonnenten
der ist auch wir haben stiefeln oder
chris ist auf jeden fall am start
ja auch so scheiße und aber irgendwie in
diesem anderen mitteilte von sylt also
das lassen wir mal team nicht machen
weil diese erhoffen
ich bin ja nicht einmal weit ich hab'
ich endlich das dritte oder getötet also
bis witzig hat nur noch ein leben ich
verstehe jetzt ganz kurz ein paar videos
zusammen wahrscheinlich abspann
oder wenn ich nicht werden heute also
ich habe mir vorgenommen habe einen
ablaufplan hier aufgestellt hier ich
nehme meine karte einzige ausnahme
das sind alles sachen die ich mir
vorgenommen habe hochzuladen und alice
steht ganz am ende das sylt video von
allen sachen die wir auf sylt machen und
zwar film ich dass die ganze zeit immer
mal was dann am ende in einen langen
die lok hoch so wie ich das zum beispiel
auch in hamburg gemacht habe ein
bisschen mitnehmen und so war sie
wollten halt surfen gehen rasch möglich
machen oder auch ich habe es gesehen so
flasche boys aus kalifornien haben sich
haben sich wasserpistole gekauft hätte
ich auf jeden fall mal boxen deshalb die
nächsten tage auch immer wieder gemacht
auf die waffe drauf und alles möglich
und so manche sachen das wird auf jeden
fall richtig geil und ich war richtig
viel filme das werden richtig langes
video wo ich den ganzen zusammen fassen
letztendlich wäre ich wahrscheinlich gar
nichts film aber ich habe auf jeden fall
hat ein video bei den urlaub das wollte
ganz schnell sagen die zweite mit super
smash bros wollen wir einfach rausgehen
können heute auch gesagt ein schlosser
got peace mich dann mit einfach ich
hoffe es funktioniert
vorhin hat super geklappt nicht mithilfe
lobby ich komm ich getan habe
es dauert nur ewigkeiten weil aber
gerade ein bisschen lobby neuen meister
genau das verlangten abi neues organ den
nächsten server du musst mich erst mal
eine partie aber wir sind jetzt
inhaltlich normal dass wyss platz nehmen
ich weiß sie bisher immer gegen diese
places verlor so schon wieder nicht mit
der polizei
ein spaß der service cool aber er
verliert
er will ich kann mir auch nicht raus
egal später gerade einmal ganz kurz
machte mich doch wieder aus jetzt kommt
mir aber egal das bringt uns nicht aus
der ruhe
und jetzt hier reinkommt schon tempo
teams einfach schnell und die hand geben
so langsam bin okay wir nehme ich mir
nehme ich mir nämlich ich weiß echt ich
will ich glaub ich nehme auch
unternehmen haben dieses coole skelett
fährt alter das war nicht so geil
das sind die basics ja davon bin ich
hier mit spinne einfach nicht im
normalen alltag bleibt ruhig jetzt
rasiere ich okay anmelder pass auf oder
schon wieder ein typ ja auch laser die
rockets insel hier
ich hasse es ging player samsung gehört
ihm darf man hier spielen muss noch
copyright machen der markt nächsten er
mag es nicht wenn man copyright macht
die kacke ich einfach auch mal 50 sollte
dieses spiel nicht spielen
alles für schüler der 10
liu kaufen ich habe diese kaputt
gegangen nach ja ohne spaß digitalen
alltag man kann er hier nicht mal ein
mal chillen so ein bisschen mal so ein
bisschen videoproduktion betreiben wer
will schon auf meinem vater hat gestimmt
und fünfziger jetzt verzieht euch doch
mal so einer ist tot
aber ich bin auch ein bisschen zwei
leben manchmal etwas einer von den
andern sterberisiko ja irgendwann mit
einer von den anderen weil ich von ihm
an oder konsti einer von beiden soll
sterben
da kommt dann habe ich gar nie jemand
ihm die gehen zusammen auf mich drauf
diese beide passten nicht zusammen thema
bewegt ich schon wieder tot ich bin eher
so möhl
ich weiß noch die zeit wo ich noch gut
hier drin war ich habe gar kein tech
spektren die gäste nicht einfach
gefallen dass irgendjemand anders mich
irgendwie berührt doch youtube.com jetzt
ich glaub an dich du schaffst es
ich sehe ich dich dass mein herz
ich bin tot ja max gut ich bin verdammt
wir sind beide keine luft der vorrunde
gewann aber okay wir aufnehmen dann
verliert marita ab
wer nicht passiert nichts oder lasst mal
es passiert gar nichts
ein server 1 komme ich raus erst mal die
lobby noch einen choral komm ich wollte
party mit mir selbst mache ich mach du
bist du noch wie einst ich bin daher
game manuel roger besten tag und sprang
lange vorher sagen naja egal dann spiele
ich keine sekunde alleine mein gott dann
rasiere ich nicht bestimmt aufrückt denn
jetzt nicht wieder mein rivers klett
mein gott schafft das noch um mein gott
oh mein gott ist es klappt man sollte
man nur da wo ich es geschafft
so jetzt geht's los gehts bringen
wenn wir jetzt gewinnen wenn ich nicht
dabei bin dann mache ich mir echt sorgen
da hätte ich dich nicht runter gezogen
man das wirkt mit erzfeind verschmerzen
so ich mache aber das amt übernehmen
weil bisher konzentrierte das sieht ja
ein bisschen
so hat mich an was heute schon mal
ändern runtergeht deutsche stuntman
das ist super kassierst du hast jedoch
fest lambo nein ja klar meint herbermann
meine vulva bombe ist einfach mal kaputt
gegangen ist durch ihn durch geflogen
man habe ich einmal hier an image sollte
man meinen ein mann standen image wörter
jetzt wenn ich ihn ja genau wie kratzer
oder sebastian hueber was dieser
natürlich
er ist auch in seinen internen ratings
immer ganz anders
caspar ist der immer treffe oder nein
der es nicht anders
er redet ganz gemein sein schweiz
interviews und dann hat er so eine
komische stimmung
er redet doch immer so der den wurm
woran liegt das nochmals meine
kommentare ich weiß dass ich auch mit
ein paar schrammen walter das war ein
cooler mutter einfach zum image
gewechselt direkt eingeplant steller
straße wird so richtig zum karate kid
mit dabei sind auch noch im krieg
getötet weil er ist los mit mir ist noch
nie geschafft
oh mein gott wer nicht geil alter sind
fünf leute in der runde
das gebäck her denken wir jetzt mein
leben ich drei bin einfach nicht mehr
nicht nur in deutschland weniger als das
gras man hat mich auch noch ein hund
getötet soll nur zwei henry lanka pongau
oder will
wir können auf jeden fall mein kommentar
schreiben was euro plänen für die
sommerferien sind oder gar nicht auch
auf sylt dieser klasse der kanal wieder
runter fliegen macht er sich zum schnee
weg es gibt auch mit
das kann doch nicht sein eine bombe ist
schon wieder durch geflogen dort nicht
mehr normal junge jeder ein leben
absolutes das match jeder hat ein leben
von fünf leuten als heftig einfach
irgendwohin können
macht die post die taktik einer schon
tot
heute kam ein eigenes angriffig
verwechselst du damit dritter nein mein
gott oh mein gott ich wollte zum image
wechsel und mein image war selber ihn
wie unten oder so aber das wird cool
bekämpft auch und ich gesehen hat das
war schon krass
es war das letzte spiel war so richtig
komisch jeder hat war gleich gut
und am ende hatte jeder nur noch einen
leben da man 2 raus und aber ich war so
mittel gut an aber der letzte kampf es
gab auch schon wieder so beschreibt das
ganze spiel so richtig viel power
attacken richtig taktisch richtig gut
man richtig gute partie auf jeden fall
klappen die ersten kommentator verloren
gegangen was den kommentator verloren
gegangen habe ich gesagt
manni breuckmann und frank buschmann
das macht der staat über die außen
der abiturient antizipieren
aber meine schnauze halten alle die fifa
14 spieler wissen dass bisher gewinnt
alter die empfänger nur ein leben
oh mein gott der schneemann es mal so
weit ist den kampf ja das ist richtig
krass gerade warte jetzt richtig
intensiv der kam ich habe noch nie
glaube ich einen guten kampf gesehen
anzupassen märz vor allem bei der nur
noch ein leben als das geil ich schreibe
schon mal dgb ist das stark er schafft
es dann kurz bezeichnet da ist mir egal
für mich ich habe auch noch weiter so
sieht einfach keine harten boden der kö
aus dem boden alter ist das ein krasser
kampf alter ich habe noch nie so einen
klassenkampf erlebt qualität der
mannschaft nahe stehen
doch der steht man ist doch noch da
alter ist das krass ich habe noch nie so
eine krasse kampf erlebte super special
ops junge das musst du dir auf jeden
fall nachher anschauen
der schneemann das unten den karten von
alt aber das krass als sie
jg ende als rom ein gott war das gute
alte räder stellen einfach hier ist sie
vor das waren richtig krasser kampe ja
echt cool
naja leute wenn es euch gefallen hat er
eventuell super smash mops wollt ihr
euch auf den urlaub freut
und wenn ihr krankhaft das haare toll
findet und es ist gut findet wie oft
ärgerlich er mit seinen händen
durchfährt in seinen videos dann gibt
auf jeden fall mal mag ich ab dann sucht
das best-of davon
es gibt das thema mein gott
dazu machen sie alles zusammen zu
schneiden weil ich mache das einen
relativ selten ich könnte das auch
machen aber medien blitz von diesem bild
werde wieder 10.000 facebook fotos
gemacht egal ist und freude
wir fahren bald in urlaub wir sind
gerade am aufnehmen dafür wir sind
gerade daran vorproduzieren des tragen
wenn ein bisschen verrückt im kopf drin
aber wie ich besuchte ich ja auch da
werden wir auch noch ein paar videos
drehen
wer bin ich werden wir machen das macht
simon zurzeit ganz häufig das wort
dieser monster machen wird probiert
warum haus unsere befragung gibt auch
risiken entstehen
egal wir checken ab wenn ihr mehr wollt
schreibt uns eure ip sender beschreiben
ich nicht vergesse das muss ja die
ganzen beschreibungen bei dir machen ich
lade alles über markt ist auch egal
tschüss